on quitte le monde du hiphop on va faire
le grand écart à présent on parler du
Grand Paris Express tout à l'heure et
clair à présent nous parlons du Machine
to Machine le M to m et oui alors on
connaissait le B2B on va parler
maintenant du M2M je vous préviens tout
de suite à part le nom ça n'a rien à
voir M2M ça veut dire Machine to Machine
c'est-à-dire des machines ou des objets
qui sont connectés qui peuvent
communiquer alors c'est un système qui
explose ces temps-ci toutes les
entreprises intéresse tout secteur
confondu pour comprendre de quoi il
s'agit exactement on retrouve pardon
Malo genenquin bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
entre autres responsable du marché M2M à
Bull donc une société d'informatique qui
a son siège à au clés sousbois alors
pour parler du M2M on utilise souvent le
terme d'objet
connecté finalement qu'est-ce qu'un
objet connecté un objet connecté c'est
un objet qui est tout d'abord
intelligent c'est-à-dire qu'il va avoir
une certain certain autonomie une
capacité à déclencher des traitements
par lui-même ensuite il va communiquer
soit avec des centrales
informatiques soit avec d'autres objets
ça l'air assez simple he quand on vous
écoute mais je suis pas sûr que le grand
public est vraiment saisi cette notion
en tout cas nous quand on s'est posé la
question en rédaction on nétait pas bien
sûr on est allé poser la question à
quelques cquantinois écoutter Machine to
Machine aucune idée ce serait d'un
procédé de fabrication peut-être machine
tout machine vous savez les gens il sont
des machines actuellement voilà quelque
chose un film de science-fiction ou les
machines fabriquerai des machines je
sais pas quelque chose comme Terminator
ou
peut-être je sais pas je sais vraiment
pas aucune idée aucune idée non je sais
pas c'est un un dialogue
euh
par comment dire sans fil entre des
instruments qui sont
équipé
d'un un moyen de communiquer entre eux
et voilà une bonne réponse sur
l'ensemble de la matiné on a entendu de
la science-fiction non c'est une réalité
aujourd'hui le Machine to Machine
véritablement on n'est pas dans le
domaine de la science-fiction non tout à
fait en fait le Machine to Machine vous
accompagne déjà au quotidien tout au
long de votre journée pour commencer
quand vous êtes à la maison vous avez
certainement une box Télécom une box
internet qui vous permet d'accèder à
Internet de téléphoner de voir la
télévision cette box elle se configure
toute seule l'époque où vous deviez
installer avec un CD Rom votre box cette
époque est révolu euh donc ça c'est du
Machine to Machine ensuite vous sortez
de chez vous vous prenez votre voiture
euh là vous allez avoir d'autres
capteurs qui vont rentrer en jeu euh
votre voiture peut déjà communiquer je
suppose que beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent et utilisent les solutions
pour détecter les zones dangereuses vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ça c'est légal
les zones dangereuses on a le droit he
c'est légal absolument c'est détecteur
de radar qu' le sont un peu moins et
bien ces boîtiers là permettent à chaque
conducteur de partager avec les autres
leur découverte de zone dangereuse et là
on est aussi dans une application en
place du Machine to Machine exactement
alors alors justement on les entreprises
en fait utilisent ce système pour
optimiser leur leur production leurs
services c'est quelque chose qui qui
leur est grandement utile est-ce que
vous auriez un exemple concret pour
qu'on voit mieux enfin l'intérêt pour
une entreprise h HM alors on peut citer
l'exemple des distributeurs de boisson
vous allez à la fois voir l'intérêt pour
les usagers mais aussi pour les
entreprises qui gèent ces distributeurs
un distributeur de boisson classique et
bien il va se vider et puis un
technicien va venir en général trop tôt
ou trop tard pour réapprovisionner la
machine si ce distributeur dispose des
technologies Machine to Machine et bien
là c'est la machine qui va prendre
l'initiative de solliciter un technicien
en lui disant attention d'ici demain je
vais tomber en panne de soda de café il
faut que tu vient de me voir donc le
technicien vient juste à temps ce qui va
permettre donc à l'entreprise qui
exploite les distributeurs d'économiser
sur ses coûts d'intervention sur site de
gagner du temps en fait sur le sur le
trajet oui euh ce qui marche aussi pas
mal c'est dans le secteur de l'énergie
vous avez en fait notamment développé
une gestion automatisée d'une miniferme
solaire c'est ça absolument nous aidons
nous réfléchissons avec un fabricant
français de panneaux photovoltaïques qui
a constitué une offre de mini ferme
solaire
destinée tout à la fois je dirais au
marché du luxe c'est-à-dire des hôtels 5
étoiles proches de
l'équateur mais aussi aux écoles
euh qui sont dans des dans des endroits
reculés proches du désert donc des
endroits qui ne sont pas desservis par
les réseaux électriques et bien ce genre
de mini ferme solaire va permettre donc
de développer l'activité la ferme
solaire c'est non seulement des panneaux
photovoltaïques mais c'est aussi un
ensemble un ensemble d'équipements
pardon qui sont qui sont assez complexes
qu'il faut pouvoir superviser suivre au
quotidien et bien nos solutions
justement permettent de suivre ça à
distance donc d'éviter d'avoir envoy des
techniciens dans ces dans ces zones trop
souvent et un autre avantage va être de
restituer au aux usagers de cette
solution donc soit des hôtels soit des
écoles reculer et bien ils vont pouvoir
visualiser facilement leur production
électrique voir ce qui fonctionne bien
ce qui fonctionne mal donc tout le monde
est content alors ce qui fonctionne bien
ce qui fonctionne mal donc ça peut être
aussi par exemple pour une entreprise
lui permettre d'économiser sa
consommation d'énergie par exemple un
système qui éteint automatiquement le
chauffage ou les lumières si les
capteurs repère qu'il n'y a personne
dans la pièce exactement exactement on
peut imaginer la même solution également
pour le domicile c'est le même
principe alors je j'ai noté en fait que
votre société avait développé un un
système pour gérer des écrans aussi dans
les métros on en voit en fait ici dans
les ivelines pouvez nous expliquer un
peu ce système oui bien sûr
c'est une solution pour ces fameux
écrans LCD que vous trouvez dans le
métro dans les gares rgion parisienne
voilà ce sont des écrans publicitaires
de nouvelle génération qui donc
transportent des FL numériques fréquente
pas le métro voilà absolument donc là
vous voyez sur la gauche d'ailleurs un
de nos développeurs tout fier d'avoir
développé la solution donc ce que l'on
fait dans ce cas-là ça ne se voit pas
c'est la technologie transparente c'est
tout ce qui va permettre de de
téléopérer téléadministrer ses écrans
publicitaires à
distance alors pour pour bien comprendre
en fait vous nous avez préparé vraiment
excusez-moi un schéma
explicatif on va peut-être le voir VO un
instant pour bien comprendre comment
cela fonctionne voà alors au niveau de
la
technique vous avez donc différentes
étapes vous pouvez un peu nous expliquer
ça part des capteurs h absolument des
capteurs et des actionneurs que l'on va
trouver aussi bien dans l'habitat au
bureau dans votre véhicule dans des
camions je dis bien capteur et
actionneur puisqu'on peut non seulement
mesurer des événements mais on peut
aussi déclencher des actions
euh après après ces équipements là on va
souvent trouver des concentrateurs qui
vont concentrer précisément les mesures
les mesures de température par exemple
sur un quartier sur une ville et qui
vont Remon monter cette information là
vers des centres informatiques où se
trouve la véritable intelligence de
traitement des
informations le transfert des
informations se fait au travers de
réseau de télécommunication
nécessairement aussi bien des réseaux
fixes ça peut être votre réseau ADSL des
réseaux de fibre optique ça peut être
aussi des réseaux mobiles bien sûr et et
également des réseaux satellitaires
imaginez un cargo en plein milieu de
l'Atlantique on peut difficilement lui
connecter une box ADSL euh donc on
arrive au centrale informatique c'est là
que toutes ces informations volumineuses
on va parler de Big Data vont être
agréger filtrer traiter on va leur
donner du sens on va les valoriser pour
ensuite les mettre à disposition des
exploitants alors on peut imaginer par
exemple que ce soit les exploitants de
ces fameux écrans publicitaires on peut
imaginer que ça soit une ville qui va
optimiser son trafic multi mul modal en
fonction des événements des bouchons des
incidents des événements sportifs ou
culturels qui sont parfois imprévisible
et euh pour exploiter facilement ces
données on va avoir des interfaces
graphiques aussi bien sur des
ordinateurs classiques que sur tous ces
nouveaux device que sont les smartphones
les tablettes et la télévision connectée
bien sûr al on peut revoir juste la la
précédente carte le petit schéma
explicatif que l'on vient de de
décrypter pour bien comprendre c'était
la carte juste avant si en régie on
arrive à rattraper cette carte et puis
dans un instant on va aussi faire un
point avec un reportage qui va nous
montrer une application concrète on va
se rendre sur le terrain voilà on va se
rendre donc au relais vous allez voir en
fait que le
M2M leur permet de gagner en efficacité
notamment sur la
tournée au relais de Chantelou les
vignes on récolte 15 à 16 tonnes de
vêtements chaque jour ici on trie à la
main le linge à recycler ou à
redistribuer un peu partout dans le
monde au premier prier AB bord une
entreprise bien loin des technologies de
pointe et pourtant depuis quelques
années déjà le relais utilise le M2M le
Machine to Machine un système qui permet
à des objets de collecter envoyer et
traiter des données sans intervention
humaine alors en fait on a une balise
dans dans le véhicule sur la partie
avant et et donc on a une transmission
de données et donc grâce à ce retour là
on va avoir grâce au logiciel
l'information sur les coordonnées xy
avec l'UR précise la quinzaine de
véhicules est géolocalisé les trajets
connus en direct tout comme l'avancée de
la
collecte donc voici le planning
journalier de de la collecte avec
l'ensemble de nos véhicules qui sont
donc notés sur le le côté gauche chacun
a donc un certain nombre de collecteurs
à vider dans la journée lorsque le
collecteur donc est vidé la case est
grisée donc on on connaît donc
l'avancement de de la la tournée euh et
puis donc tous ceux en en orange sont
des des collecteurs restant restant à
viidé autre application du M2M des
sondes cachées dans les containers le
système nécessite encore d'être rodé
mais devrait permettre à terme de
connaître le taux de remplissage et
d'organiser la collecte plus
intelligemment bah ça nous permet
d'économiser de gagner du temps de
rationaliser nos tournées qu'on parle de
rationalisation on est du coup sur moins
de déplacement donc en coût et puis en
en B en bonne c'est évidemment meilleur
au relais le M2M permet donc de gérer la
flotte et la collecte mais de nombreuses
autres applications sont possibles
économie d'énergie gestion de stock ou
même maintenance de cœur artificiel le
M2M englobe tous les
secteurs on espère que le M2M le Machine
to Machine c'est un peu moins abstrait
pour vous à présent nous avons le
responsable du marché M2M pour la
société Bou donc qui est implanté au
clés sous-bois sur ce plateau on peut
parler d'un véritable développement un
boom he dans les années à venir
notamment pour l'entreprise boule avec
plusieurs milliers d'euros sur le
développement du chiffre d'affaires
vraiment quelque chose de de
véritablement important plusieurs
millions même plusieurs millions
effectivement j'ai même sousestimer vous
voyez donc justement en fait ce
développement qu'est-ce qui est envisagé
dans le futur vous avez pas mal de
projets à venir c'est ça oui absolument
ça foisonne on peut citer quelques
projets particulièrement intéressants
autour de l'habitat intelligent et la
capacité des maisons du futur à
s'adapter à vous plutôt que l'inverse
on peut aussi citer l'agriculture 2.0
avec une aide aux fermiers pour
exploiter bien le leur chtel par exemple
il y aura aussi l'aide à la jardinerie
de manière très concrète c'est-à-dire
qu'on va avoir des capteur dans votre
plante préférée pour savoir s'il faut
l'arroser rajouter des engrais des
plantes bioniques à l'avenir alors pres
absolument absolument des plantes
bioniques des moutons bioniques qui nous
alerteront qu'il faut venir s'occuper
d'eux c'est un petit peu ça l'avenir du
M2M on peut le voir comme ça
voilàématiser un petit peu et puis il
aura bien sûr tout ce qui est santé qui
est qui est un territoire extrêmement
prometteur merci d'être venu nous parler
de ces différentes technologies sur le
plateau clair on continue la chronique
de l'cho avec les infos en plus oui
alors tout d'abord la fusion complète de
Fiat et chrsler qui est attendu en 2014
alors le patron de Fiat Sergio marchion
si je prononce bien a fait cette annonce
dimanche dernier donc ça ne s'est pas
passé au siège français à trappe mais
c'était en Italie Fiat est déjà
actionnaire à 60 % et selon Monsieur
marquionet les 40 % restants ne seraiit
plus qu'une question d'argent le but
afficher réorienter la stratégie du
groupe vers le haut de
gamme Fiat ou christler excusez-moi
quelle marque restera-t-il il a annoncé
en fait qu'il n'avait pas encore pensé
au futur de N groupe donc ça reste à
découvrir vous avez appris l'italien non
vous avez pas une formation en italien à
tout un bilan sur le travail intérimaire
à présent oui alors c'est un bilan assez
morose tout de même on a eu les chiffres
du baromètre prisme emploi il montre que
par rapport à décembre 2011 le mois de
décembre dernier à une chute de 11,9 %
en terme d'effectif d'intérimaire c'est
une baisse à relativiser puisque ça
reste une une chute un peu moindre que
le reste de l'île-de-fance où on aperçu
une une baisse de 13,2 %. donc ces
chiffres restent tout de même
préoccupants puisqu'on considère
l'intérim comme un indicateur du marché
de l'emploi et en général ça préfigure
les tendance du recrutement et pour
terminer ces infos en plus résultat du
concours de l'entreprise numérique
artisanale prix décerné le 5 février il
y a quelques jours vous allez nous
donner le palmarès très bement voilà
alors c'est un sujet donc un peu plus
joyeux ça récompenser donc des
entreprises artisanales des yvelin qui
utilisent le numérique pour développer
leur activité donc il concourit dans
trois catégories tout d'abord l'usage
numérique pour l'affirmation et la
promotion de l'entreprise donc c'est
tout ce qui est site internet et cetera
on voit là en image donc le site ce qui
a été récompensé qui est délise
undereg 2uxèe catégorie c'est l'usage
numérique en gestion d'entreprise qui
peut être par exemp télédéclaration ou
plan comptable qui revient à eradom et
enfin l'usage numérique en production
qui revient à Deep révision SAS un
système d'imagerie et les trois
entreprises ont remporté 1000 €.
l'agenda très brièvement siil a une date
à retenir alors ce qui a une déenir on
peut parler en fait de deux ateliers qui
peuvent préparer à la semaine de
l'emploi donc c'est l'atelier sur
l'importance du look qui sera donc à la
Cité des Métiers de trappe à 9h30 demain
et enfin toujours à la Cité des Métiers
un atelier CV et l'aide de motivation ce
sera lundi de 14 à 16h merci Claire
voilà on va vous arrêter sur votre
lancée merci dans un instant la suite de
cette édition du 78 nous parlerons santé
comment accompagner les famille
d'enfants malades nous en parlerons avec
la directrice de l'hôpital pédiatrique
de bulion auparavant le nouvel an
chinois c'est en ce moment et nous y
avons forcément consacré ce
reportage dimanche 10 février marquera
le début du nouvel an chinois ou plutôt
nouvel an lunaire puisque tous les
peuples d'Asie célèbrent cet événement
symbolique le passage au premier jour du
premier mois du calendrier chinois comme
chaque année la nouvelle année c'est
bonne santé réussite
et prospérité quoi on espère que avec la
nouvelle année on chasse tous les tous
les
mauvais
esprits et de d'emmener tout ce qui est
de de bien
dans pour la pour l'année qui arrive si
les vœux asiatiques pour la nouvelle
année restent les mêmes que la
Communauté française le poids des
traditions spirituel n'est pas le même
comme pour le président de l'Amicale
vietnamienne de 5 an iveline père de
trois enfants et bientôt trois fois
grand-père il fêtera dès samedi soir et
durant 3 jours l'arrivée de la nouvelle
année en présence de tous les membres de
sa famille dans la cérémonie on demande
les géniees de la terre les génie de la
maison de laisser passer les
ancêtres le premier jour des
célébrations sa femme cuisinera
uniquement des plats végétariens et des
plats réservés aux génies invoqués ainsi
qu'aux ancêtres à la fin des 3 jours de
repas ils inviteront leurs ancêtres à
rentrer chez eux lors d'une dernière
cérémonie après les festivités
familiales le couple de Vietnamiens se
réunira avec la communauté
cinquantinoise le 2 mars pour un dîner
dansant du nouvel an lunaire près de 146
familles adhèrent à cette amicale qu'ils
ont Condé à leur arrivée à montig le
Bretonneux il y a 30 ans toujours
nourris par l'envie de se regroup entre
compatriotes parfois réfugiés et de
perpétuer leur culture il proposent des
activités
cours de vietnamien pour adultes et
enfants danse de salon et séance de Tai
ou chicon des gymnastiques du corps et
de l'esprit alors bonne année du serpent
d'au